From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And our program today really began at a dinner conversation about a month ago. Three members of the This American Life staff-- Alix, Nancy and Paul-- were eating together.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目其实源于一个月前的一次晚餐谈话。三位《美国生活》的员工——艾历克斯、南希和保罗——当时正在一起用餐。
Well, we were all out at Leo's.
嗯，我们当时都在里奥餐厅。
I don't know how it came up. I don't know which one of us brought it up.
我不知道是怎么聊到这个话题的。我不知道是我们中的哪个人提起来的。
I don't know how it started. I don't know how it first came up.
我不知道它是怎么开始的。我不知道它是怎么第一次被提出来的。
I don't even remember how we got on the topic, honestly.
说实话，我甚至不记得我们是怎么聊到这个话题的。
But we started mentioning Canadians. And I guess I was doing most of it, as the Canadian in the group.
但我们开始提起加拿大人。我想大概是我说得最多，毕竟我是小组里的那个加拿大人。
He started with William Shatner, and I thought that was wrong.
他先提到了威廉·夏特纳，我当时觉得那是错的。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
That he was Canadian.
说他是加拿大人。
People got increasingly freaked out.
人们变得越来越震惊。
That's what he said about him.
他就是这么说的。
That's all he said about him.
他关于他也就只说了这些。
That he was Canadian, yeah.
说他是加拿大人，没错。
And what's the problem with that?
那这有什么问题吗？
Well, the problem is that I grew up watching Star Trek. And he is like my American ideal. I mean, he represented for me everything that's good about America, in a way.
问题在于，我是看着《星际迷航》长大的。他简直是我的美国偶像。我的意思是，在某种程度上，他代表了美国一切美好的事物。
Alix was saying, if William Shatner is Canadian, I might as well be Canadian.
艾历克斯当时说，如果威廉·夏特纳是加拿大人，那我干脆也当加拿大人算了。
It isn't just that there are Canadians among us, it's that they're at the very epicenter of our culture. It's the guy who created Saturday Night Live and Jim Carrey and Michael J. Fox. It's Mike Myers and the blond from Baywatch , Pamela Anderson Lee, and the director of the Terminator films, James Cameron. It's Matthew Perry and Jason Priestley, Alanis Morissette and Celine Dion, and the bassist in Courtney Love's band, Hole.
不仅仅是因为我们中间有加拿大人，而是因为他们正处于我们文化的核心。有创造了《周六夜现场》的那个人，有金·凯瑞和迈克尔·J·福克斯。有麦克·迈尔斯，还有《海滩救护队》里的金发美女帕梅拉·安德森·李，以及《终结者》系列的导演詹姆斯·卡梅隆。还有马修·派瑞、杰森·普雷斯利、艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特、席琳·迪翁，甚至还有考特妮·洛夫的乐队Hole里的贝斯手。
I remember Alix being continually and repeatedly amazed.
我记得艾历克斯当时一直感到非常惊讶。
I was shocked. I was very shocked.
我惊呆了。我真的非常震惊。
I mean, she stopped eating, I think. And it wasn't just that she'd be shocked at one and would then sort of go on. She'd come back to ones that were shocking earlier. "Peter Jennings? I can't believe it!"
我的意思是，我想她连饭都不吃了。而且不仅仅是对一个人感到震惊，她还反复提起那些之前让她震惊的人。“彼得·詹宁斯？我简直不敢相信！”
I remember Alix being really freaked out about Peter Jennings,
我记得艾历克斯对彼得·詹宁斯感到非常抓狂。
Peter Jennings, especially.
尤其是彼得·詹宁斯。
But he's just a news reader.
但他只是个读新闻的。
But he delivers information about America to Americans.
但他向美国人传递关于美国的信息。
He's like the leader who binds us together?
他就像是把我们团结在一起的领袖？
Yeah, and he interprets our culture for us. So it's like having some Czechoslovakian as your vice president or something. I mean, it's just wrong. There's something about that that's wrong.
是的，他为我们解读我们的文化。所以这就好比让一个捷克斯洛伐克人当你们的副总统一样。我的意思是，这简直是错的。这背后肯定有什么地方不对劲。
She just thought it was wrong, that actually, there should be an actual law against it.
她就是觉得这不对劲，实际上，应该有一条法律禁止这种行为。
For there to be a Canadian broadcasting the news?
禁止加拿大人播报新闻？
Well, anchoring. I think CNN, she probably would let a CNN anchor be Canadian, but not ABC.
嗯，播音。我想CNN的话，她可能允许CNN主播是加拿大人，但ABC不行。
Well, I think that Americans generally think of Canadians as a pretty quiet, nondescript, stay-at-home kind of culture. And when Canadians come to the United States and have that kind of impact on the culture, I think it's a surprising fact. But I also think that it's a little disturbing and spooky to Americans because they haven't known. It's like suddenly discovering that everything you believed about someone was false.
嗯，我认为美国人通常认为加拿大人是一个相当安静、平淡、居家型的文化。当加拿大人来到美国并在文化上产生这种影响时，我认为这确实是个令人惊讶的事实。但也正因为美国人一直不知情，这让他们感到有些不安和诡异。这就像突然发现你一直相信的关于某人的一切都是假的。
I guess it's the whole invasion of the body snatchers syndrome. They look like us, but they're not us.
我想这就是整个“人体入侵者”综合症。他们看起来像我们，但他们不是我们。
It's weirdly like people hearing that somebody they didn't know was gay is gay, and it turned them back on themselves, that they could have brushed so close and not known.
这奇怪地就像人们听说一个他们以为是异性恋的人其实是同性恋一样，这让他们开始反思自己，反思自己竟然与之如此亲近却浑然不知。
He's Canadian, so that's why he never married.
他是加拿大人，所以他才一直没结婚。
Exactly.
正是如此。
The thing about the Canadians among us is it's not clear what it means.
关于我们中间的这些加拿大人，奇怪的是这到底意味着什么并不清楚。
Well, I think that's part of what is so compelling about it. It doesn't suggest anything. It's not that, oh, he's Russian. He must be communist. Oh, he's French, he must be rude. It's just a sense that they're a little off somehow, in some way that you don't understand, and you can't pin it down. And that makes it all the more unsettling. You can't put it anywhere and just have it rest there. It's just sort of continually surprising and disturbing.
嗯，我认为这正是它如此引人入胜的原因。它并不暗示什么。并不是说，“噢，他是俄罗斯人，那他一定是共产主义者。噢，他是法国人，那他一定很粗鲁。”这只是一种感觉，觉得他们有些不对劲，以一种你无法理解也无法确定的方式。这让事情变得更加令人不安。你没法把它归类并置之不理。它就是那样持续不断地让人感到惊讶和困扰。
Well, today on our program, we try to make some sense out of what it means, having this Canadian menace among us, if it is a menace. All this hour, stories by and about the Canadians in our midst. Act One, White Like Me, one Canadian's attempt at passing in New York City. Act Two, The World's Most Perfect Pneumatic Vacuum, in which our own Sarah Vowell arm wrestles with Ian Brown of the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation over what it means to be an American and what it means to be a Canadian and if they are any different at all. Act Three, Outing. An expose on the pro-Canadian bias and Peter Jennings' nightly newscast for ABC, and more. Act Four, Who's Canadian? Two siblings separated, not at birth. One gone to live in Winnipeg, one gone to live in Manhattan. Their stories. Stay with us.
那么，今天在我们的节目中，我们将尝试理清这种“加拿大威胁”——如果它确实是一种威胁的话——在我们中间究竟意味着什么。在这一小时里，我们将讲述关于我们身边的加拿大人以及由他们创作的故事。第一幕，“像我一样的白人”，一个加拿大人试图融入纽约市的尝试。第二幕，“世界上最完美的气动真空”，我们自己的莎拉·沃威尔将与加拿大广播公司的伊恩·布朗进行扳手腕式的辩论，探讨身为美国人和身为加拿大人意味着什么，以及他们之间到底有什么不同。第三幕，“出柜”。一篇关于彼得·詹宁斯在ABC夜间新闻中存在亲加拿大偏见的报道，以及更多内容。第四幕，“谁是加拿大人？”两名失散的兄妹，并非出生时失散。一个去了温尼伯，一个去了曼哈顿。他们的故事。请继续收听。
Act One, White Like Me. As a 17-year-old, David Rakoff moved from Toronto, Ontario, to New York City. He's been there now for half his life, works in publishing and as a writer and actor. This American Life listeners may remember his story about portraying Sigmund Freud in the Christmas windows at Barney's a few months ago. David Rakoff says that from the day that he arrived in New York City, he decided he was going to try to efface his Canadian-ness and pass for a local.
第一幕，“像我一样的白人”。17岁时，大卫·拉科夫从安大略省多伦多搬到了纽约市。他已经在那里度过了他半辈子的人生，从事出版业，也是一名作家和演员。《美国生活》的听众可能还记得他几个月前讲述的在巴尼斯百货圣诞橱窗里扮演西格蒙德·弗洛伊德的故事。大卫·拉科夫说，从他到达纽约市的那一天起，他就决定要尝试抹去自己的加拿大色彩，伪装成一个本地人。
My tactics were to adopt a certain kind of world-weary, jaded, anxious neuroticism. And it was taken on as a cosmetic mantle at the beginning until such time as you simply can't pull the mask off your face. Oh my god, it's stuck. There you are years later, a jaded, affectless, neurotic, disenchanted, sad person. But that's fine.
我的策略是表现出一种愤世嫉俗、焦虑且神经质的姿态。起初这只是一种外在的伪装，直到有一天你发现你根本无法把面具从脸上摘下来。天哪，它粘住了。几年后，你成了这样一个愤世嫉俗、面无表情、神经质、心灰意冷且悲伤的人。但那也无所谓。
Would you consciously not bring up the fact that were from Canada at any point, when you think back on those years?
回想那些年，你是否曾有意识地不提及你是来自加拿大这个事实？
No. No, I would never consciously not bring it up. I would occasionally consciously bring it up because it would-- amazingly enough-- make me more exotic. Because let's face it, in New York City, I'm a Jewish guy with dark hair who works in publishing with a gift for the gab. I meet myself coming and going 12 to 14 times an hour. So occasionally, I'll need that little bit of spice. And what's more spicy than being Canadian? I ask you.
不。不，我从来不会有意识地不提。我偶尔反而会主动提起，因为——令人惊讶的是——这会让我显得更独特。因为面对现实吧，在纽约市，我是一个有着深色头发、从事出版业、口才极佳的犹太人。我每小时都会遇到无数个像我这样的人。所以偶尔，我需要一点调味料。而还有什么比身为加拿大人更具异国情调的呢？我问你。
I'm told that Canadians tend to know who else is Canadian who's famous.
我听说加拿大人倾向于知道其他哪些加拿大人是名人。
All the time. Everything. And that, to me, is chemical. You know, the easy ones. Glenn Ford, Kate Nelligan, Hume Cronyn, Cowboy Junkies, Monty Hall--
总是这样。所有事。对我来说，这是一种化学反应。你知道，那些简单的例子。格伦·福特、凯特·内利根、休姆·克罗宁、牛仔乐队、蒙提·霍尔——
Monty Hall? Wait, Monty Hall? The host of Let's Make a Deal ?
蒙提·霍尔？等等，蒙提·霍尔？《让我们做笔交易》的主持人？
Yeah. Live and learn, huh?
是的。活到老学到老，对吧？
Who could be more American than the host of Let's Make a Deal ? Even the name Let's Make a Deal --
还有谁能比《让我们做笔交易》的主持人更美国化？甚至“让我们做笔交易”这个名字——
And  yet, remember, Monty only facilitated the deals.
然而，请记住，蒙提只是促成了交易。
[LAUGHS] And, I guess, that name, Monty.
[笑] 而且，我想，那个名字，蒙提。
There you go.
你看，就是这样。
Who else?
还有谁？
Glenn Ford, John Kenneth Galbraith. But here's the thing about knowing who's Canadian. There is a woman named Shania Twain. She is Canadian. I know that she's Canadian. I do not know who the hell Shania Twain is. I don't know what she does. And yet, for some reason, I know that she's famous in America and that she's Canadian.
格伦·福特、约翰·肯尼思·加尔布雷思。但关于“谁是加拿大人”这件事，重点在于：有一个叫仙妮亚·唐恩的女人。她是加拿大人。我知道她是加拿大人。但我根本不知道仙妮亚·唐恩是谁。我不知道她是干什么的。然而出于某种原因，我知道她在全美很有名，而且她是加拿大人。
How did this come up? Did your parents talk to you about it?
这是怎么聊起来的？你父母和你谈过这个吗？
I literally don't know. I feel there's a chip in my head or something because I simply happen to know that. Here's the other thing-- Borje Salming? Not --
我真的不知道。我觉得我脑袋里有个芯片之类的，因为我就是凑巧知道这些。还有一件事——博尔耶·萨尔明？不是——
Who?
谁？
Borje Salming. Hockey player. Not Canadian. Daryl Sittler? Yes, Canadian. Ira, I have never been to a hockey game in my entire life. How do these things enter my brain?
博尔耶·萨尔明。曲棍球运动员。不是加拿大人。达里尔·西特勒？是的，加拿大人。艾拉，我这辈子从来没看过一场曲棍球比赛。这些东西是怎么进我脑子的？
But at some point, somebody told you.
但在某个时候，有人告诉过你。
I don't even think so, you know? I just think it comes in off the breeze or in a cold front. And I know. I just know in my heart who's Canadian.
我觉得甚至没有，你知道吗？我只是觉得它们是从微风中或是冷锋中传进来的。而我就知道。我内心深处就是知道谁是加拿大人。
It's so strange. And of course, the arm on your space shuttle.
这太奇怪了。当然，还有你们航天飞机上的机械臂。
I'm sorry?
对不起？
The arm on your space shuttle for making interstellar repairs.
用于进行星际维修的航天飞机机械臂。
In Canada, the space shuttle is referred to as--
在加拿大，航天飞机被称为——
The American space shuttle with its Canadian-built arm. Never any other way, as in "The American space shuttle with its Canadian-built arm blew up today."
装有加拿大制造机械臂的美国航天飞机。从来没有别的说法，比如“今天，装有加拿大制造机械臂的美国航天飞机爆炸了”。
No, that didn't really happen.
不，那并没有真的发生。
No, well, I was actually here at the time, but the Canadian-built arm gets a lot of airplay. Not down here, huh? In fact, if you were to ask most Canadians, "What do you think the space shuttle is for?" they'd say, "Oh, to go up and move stuff around in space with an arm."
不，嗯，我当时确实在那里，但“加拿大制造的机械臂”确实得到了很多曝光。下面没有吗？事实上，如果你问大多数加拿大人，“你认为航天飞机是干什么用的？”他们会说，“噢，去太空里用机械臂挪动东西。”
And so, when a Canadian finds out that some figure is Canadian, what happens in their heart?
那么，当一个加拿大人发现某个人是加拿大人时，他们心里会发生什么？
Oh, well, your heart does a little bit of a-- a certain special Canadian's chamber opens up and enfolds that name and you keep it. Or if you mention a famous Canadian in conversation to a Canadian without acknowledging it, there's a vague flicker over their eyes like the shadow of an angel's wing passing, and then the conversation will go on and on. And then, just as an afterthought, they'll say, well, you know, he's Canadian, by the way. Of course, it's all you've been waiting to say the entire conversation.
噢，好吧，你的心会产生一种小小的……某个特殊的加拿大腔室会打开，包容那个名字，然后你就会记住它。或者如果你在与一个加拿大人交谈时提到了一个著名的加拿大人而不承认这一点，他们的眼睛会闪过一丝模糊的阴影，就像天使翅膀的阴影掠过，然后谈话会继续进行下去。然后，就像事后补充一样，他们会说，嗯，顺便说一句，他是加拿大人。当然，这其实是你整个谈话过程中一直等着要说的话。
This is in a conversation with a Canadian or a non-Canadian?
这是在与加拿大人或非加拿大人的谈话中？
If a non-Canadian says to you, and you are a Canadian. But you can do it with a Canadian too.
如果一个非加拿大人对你说——而你是一个加拿大人。但你也可以和加拿大人这样做。
But with a non-Canadian, like if you and I were talking, and I would bring up--
但如果是和非加拿大人，比如如果你和我谈话，我会提起——
Monty Hall.
蒙提·霍尔。
--Monty Hall, which happens so often.
——蒙提·霍尔，这种情况经常发生。
Why, just the other day when we were talking about what was in your purse. Remember, I asked you? And I would be compelled by DNA--
为什么，就在前几天我们讨论你的钱包里有什么的时候。记得吗，我问过你？而我会被DNA驱使——
You would actually say at some point, he's Canadian?
你真的会在某个时候说，他是加拿大人？
Not even at some point, Ira. Let's try it. Go on, you start.
甚至不是在某个时候，艾拉。我们来试试。来吧，你开始。
All right. So anyway, I was in the car on my way to work, and that song from Bachman-Turner Overdrive came on.
好的。总之，我在开车去上班的路上，巴赫曼-特纳超速乐队的那首歌响起来了。
They're Canadian. That's how I do it. I don't even wait. I don't even wait. Bachman-Turner Overdrive. They're Canadian. And then I'll tell you, "Taking Care of Business," they wrote that. They're Canadian. I don't even bother waiting. Very effective. And it always also begs the question, which is, oh, are you Canadian?
他们是加拿大人。我就是这么做的。我甚至不用等。我甚至不用等。巴赫曼-特纳超速乐队。他们是加拿大人。然后我会告诉你，“处理业务”这首歌，他们写的。他们是加拿大人。我甚至懒得等。非常有效。而且这总是引发一个问题，即，噢，你是加拿大人吗？
Really? People, then, ask that?
真的吗？人们会问那个？
Well, of course they'd ask that. It's a little unbalanced if one wasn't. Don't you think that would be somewhat strange behavior?
嗯，当然会问。如果不是的话，会有点失衡。你不觉得那会是一种有点奇怪的行为吗？
I have to say here that as somebody who grew up as a Jew in suburban Baltimore, this game of Who's a Canadian, it was very, very familiar. Every adult I knew in Baltimore played a very similar game. See now, among my parents' generation, there was the game of Who's a Jew?
我必须在这里说，作为一个在巴尔的摩郊区长大的犹太人，这种“谁是加拿大人”的游戏，非常、非常熟悉。我认识的巴尔的摩的每一个成年人都玩过类似的游戏。你看，在我父母那一代，玩的是“谁是犹太人”的游戏。
Oh, yeah. I'm somewhat familiar with that game. So can you imagine what the double triumph is if someone's a Canadian Jew? Lorne Greene. You fairly cannot imagine anyone more heroic than Lorne Greene. He's a Canadian.
噢，是的。我对那个游戏很熟悉。所以你能想象如果有人既是加拿大人又是犹太人，那是多么大的双重胜利吗？洛恩·格林。你简直无法想象比洛恩·格林更英雄的人物了。他是加拿大人。
Do you remember this coming up in your household?
你还记得在你家里提过这个吗？
Absolutely. He's Canadian, and Jewish too.
当然。他是加拿大人，也是犹太人。
Who's a Jew?
谁是犹太人？
And imagine how crestfallen everybody was when they found out that Andrea Martin of Second City TV is not just not Jewish, she's Armenian. But she's from Maine. She just lived in Canada. And then everybody shrugs and says, well, Armenians, they're very similar. And Maine, it's very close. And she lived here for so long.
试想当大家发现《第二城电视台》的安德里亚·马丁不仅不是犹太人，还是亚美尼亚人时，大家是多么失望。但她来自缅因州。她只是住在加拿大。然后每个人都耸耸肩说，嗯，亚美尼亚人，他们很像。而且缅因州，离得很近。而且她在那里住了那么久。
When you meet a Canadian, do you have certain prejudices about them once you learn that they are Canadian?
当你遇到一个加拿大人时，一旦得知他们是加拿大人，你会有某种偏见吗？
When I meet them here?
当我在这里遇到他们时？
Yeah.
是的。
Yes, I worry that they're going to be really literal and take everything that I say totally seriously-- even the throwaway remarks-- and then I'm going to have to backtrack and explain myself. I worry that they're going to blow my cover.
是的，我担心他们会非常刻板，把我说的一切都完全当真——即使是那些随口说出的俏皮话——然后我就不得不往回解释。我担心他们会拆穿我的伪装。
As a Canadian?
伪装成加拿大人？
As a Canadian masquerading as an urban sophisticate.
伪装成都市精英的加拿大人。
How would they do that in your fantasy of this?
在你的幻想中，他们会怎么做？
They would suddenly say, "You're not a sophisticated New Yorker. You're just nothing but a tobogganing Canadian." And then I always feel that I have to turn in my liquor supply and my books and return home. And then, in fact, all the quips that I made all over the years turn out to actually have been made up by someone else, even though I didn't know it.
他们会突然说，“你不是一个成熟的纽约客。你只不过是一个只会滑雪橇的加拿大人。”然后我就总是觉得我必须上缴我的酒水供应和书籍，然后回家。而且，事实上，我多年来开的所有俏皮话原来都是别人编的，尽管我并不知道。
So if you know that there's another Canadian in the room, do you feel like you've been outed in some way, and that you'll be seen as less than the sophisticate that you are?
所以如果你知道房间里有另一个加拿大人，你会觉得你以某种方式被“出柜”了，你会觉得自己不如你所表现出的精英形象吗？
That? Yes.
那样吗？是的。
You do?
你真的这么觉得？
Briefly. Briefly. And then, another kind of reserve kicks in. And one thinks, well, everybody's got to come from somewhere, don't they? And, in fact, it's a little bit even more vindicating because you have that whole sort of, not bad for a boy from Canada, sort of feeling.
短暂地。短暂地。然后，另一种矜持感就会产生。一个人会想，好吧，每个人都得来自某个地方，不是吗？而且，事实上，这甚至更具辩护意义，因为你会有一种“对于一个来自加拿大的男孩来说，还算不错”的那种感觉。
David Rakoff, immigrant. He's lived in the United States for 15 years.
大卫·拉科夫，移民。他在美国生活了15年。
When you first came to this country, there must've been differences between the two cultures that struck you.
当你刚来到这个国家时，这两种文化之间一定有什么不同让你印象深刻。
There was an adorable-- I remember going down to the deli or something one night when I was a freshman in college and looking into the dairy case and seeing what you call those individually wrapped slices of processed cheese food.
有一个很可爱的地方——我记得大一的一天晚上我去熟食店或其他什么地方，看着乳制品柜台，看到你们称之为那种独立包装的加工奶酪片。
American cheese.
美国奶酪。
Yes. And we call it Canadian cheese. And I, of course, thought, oh, isn't that cute. They're trying to take credit for Canadian cheese. And now, of course, my feeling is that we should be calling it American cheese, and you guys should be calling it Canadian cheese. It seems like something one should be throwing the blame right across the 49th parallel, whatever side you're on. But I thought, oh, that's adorable.
是的。而我们称之为加拿大奶酪。我当然想，噢，那不是很可爱吗。他们试图把功劳揽到加拿大奶酪头上。现在，当然，我的感觉是我们应该称之为美国奶酪，而你们应该称之为加拿大奶酪。这看起来像是应该在49度平行线两边互相推卸责任的事情。但我当时想，噢，那太可爱了。
So wait, so in Canada, that kind of American cheese, that is called-
等等，所以在加拿大，那种美国奶酪，被称为——
Canadian singles, yes.
加拿大单片奶酪，是的。
Canadian singles sounds like the name of some bad import movie.
加拿大单片奶酪听起来像是一部烂进口电影的名字。
Doesn't it just?
不是吗？
You know, the Canadian Cameron Crowe would write Canadian Singles , and then it would appear on cable here late at night.
你知道，加拿大版的卡梅伦·克罗会写出《加拿大单片奶酪》，然后它就会深夜在我们的有线电视上出现。
They all work in a coffeehouse in Guelph, Ontario. Some of them are majoring in animal husbandry.
他们都在安大略省圭尔夫的一家咖啡店工作。他们中有些人主修畜牧业。
David Rakoff discusses things Canadian and things American in his new book, Fraud.
大卫·拉科夫在他的新书《欺诈》中讨论了加拿大的事物和美国的事物。
[MUSIC--"TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS" BY BACHMAN-TURNER OVERDRIVE]
[音乐——巴赫曼-特纳超速乐队的“处理业务”]
Act Two, The World's Most Perfect Pneumatic Vacuum. Canadians. They get our TV shows, eat the same breakfast cereals, drive the same cars. They look like us, they speak the same language-- some of them, anyway. So are they us?
第二幕，“世界上最完美的气动真空”。加拿大人。他们看我们的电视节目，吃一样的早餐麦片，开一样的车。他们看起来像我们，说一样的语言——至少其中一些人是这样。那么他们就是我们吗？
Well, the perfect person to discuss that question with is Ian Brown. For years, he was the host of the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation's program Sunday Morning . Ian Brown is the perfect person to discuss the differences between Canadian and American culture, not only because he feels his Canadian-ness so deeply, but because he lived in the United States for years. And he loves Americans enough that he married one. He spoke with our contributing editor, Sarah Vowell, back when he was still hosting Sunday Morning .
好吧，讨论这个问题的最佳人选是伊恩·布朗。多年来，他一直担任加拿大广播公司节目《周日早晨》的主持人。伊恩·布朗是讨论加拿大文化和美国文化差异的完美人选，不仅因为他深刻地感受到了自己的加拿大身份，还因为他在美国住了多年。而且他爱美国人，爱到娶了一个。在他还在主持《周日早晨》时，他与我们的特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔进行了交谈。
Like most Americans, I don't particularly care about Canada. But every week, I spend three solid hours thinking about goings-on in Moose Jaw and Manitoba. The reason is this. Even though I don't care about Canada, I do care about radio, passionately. And my favorite radio program-- aside from this one, of course-- is Sunday Morning . And the most moving segment of the show is usually host Ian Brown's personal essay at the end.
像大多数美国人一样，我并不特别关心加拿大。但每周，我都会花整整三个小时思考麋鹿颚和曼尼托巴省发生的事情。原因是这样的：尽管我不关心加拿大，但我对广播充满激情。而我最喜欢的广播节目——当然除了这个节目以外——是《周日早晨》。而且节目中最动人的部分通常是主持人伊恩·布朗在结尾处的个人散文。
One week it's about hockey versus basketball, the next about his opposition to a separate Quebec. But what it's really about is the idea of nation. Listening to him ask questions of his country and his place in it, I get to ask those questions of mine. It's not something we tend to dwell on in American broadcasting. But Brown says that in Canada, it happens all the time. And because America's cultural presence is so huge and so near, Canadian self-reflection must, by definition, involve thinking about living next door to such a noisy neighbor.
一周是关于曲棍球与篮球的对比，下周是关于他反对魁北克独立的观点。但它真正讨论的是“国家”这个概念。听着他对自己国家和他在其中所处位置的质问，我也能对自己国家提出同样的质问。这并不是我们在美国广播中倾向于深入探讨的事情。但布朗说，在加拿大，这种情况随时都会发生。而且因为美国的文化存在如此巨大且如此临近，加拿大的自我反思按定义必须涉及思考与这样一个吵闹的邻居比邻而居。
I think we've developed the same attitudes that, say, the Pakistanis have towards India or, say, the border the Poles have to Russia. American culture somehow seizes you. But at the same time, we're not part of American culture. In fact, for years, Canadians have defined themselves-- or many Canadians have defined themselves-- as being, we're Canadian because we're not American. It's not a very good definition, but it's certainly one that a lot of people--
我想我们已经形成了同样的态度，比如巴基斯坦人对待印度，或者波兰人对待俄罗斯的边界。美国文化在某种程度上抓住了你。但与此同时，我们并不属于美国文化。事实上，多年来，加拿大人一直在定义自己——或者许多加拿大人一直在定义自己——作为“我们是加拿大人，因为我们不是美国人”。这不是一个很好的定义，但它肯定是很多人——
So when you're here without the protection of the border--
所以当你没有边界保护来到这里时——
Well, exactly.
嗯，确实。
--are you swallowed?
——你会被吞噬吗？
It's flipped around. You're always slightly afraid and slightly amazed and slightly aware that you're swirling in some huge vortex that might just suck you down. At the same time, I should say that-- and I don't know whether this is a widely shared view-- but one of the reasons why Canadians are so obsessed with America is that it is such an energetic culture. It's so important in the world. It is the great empire of the 20th century-- has been. And you can't avoid that.
情况反转了。你总是有点害怕，有点惊讶，并且意识到你正处在一个巨大的漩涡中，它可能会把你吸下去。同时，我必须说——我不知道这是否是一个广泛认同的观点——但加拿大人如此痴迷美国的原因之一是，它是一个非常有活力的文化。它在世界上非常重要。它是20世纪的伟大帝国——曾经是。而且你无法避免这一点。
Well, even before the 20th century-- I was thinking about this when I was looking at this Canadian history book over the weekend-- and how almost embarrassingly gradual your path to independence seemed, to me, And I was wondering how in the world you could teach schoolchildren about this really complicated, subtle history in a way that would be halfway inspiring.
好吧，甚至在20世纪之前——我周末在看这本加拿大历史书时就在想这个问题——你们通往独立的道路对我来说显得多么令人尴尬地缓慢。我当时在想，你们怎么可能以一种半令人鼓舞的方式教导学童这种复杂、微妙的历史呢。
Well, you've struck on quite an important point there. It often isn't inspiring because it is so gradual. We've been talking about the constitution in this country. To my direct knowledge-- I've been following it since I was about-- well, the flag debate. I was about 11, I guess.
好吧，你提出了一个非常重要的点。它往往不令人鼓舞，因为它太缓慢了。我们一直在谈论这个国家的宪法。据我直接了解——我从大约——好吧，国旗辩论开始就一直关注它。我当时大约11岁，我想。
The American flag debate?
美国国旗辩论？
No, the Canadian flag debate, when we finally got a flag of our own.
不，加拿大国旗辩论，当我们最终拥有了自己的旗帜时。
And what year was that?
那是哪一年？
Oh, that was 1965.
噢，那是1965年。
Fairly late.
相当晚了。
Oh yeah, exactly, 100 years after the Confederation.
噢是的，没错，联邦成立100年后。
Which was also fairly late, it seems to me.
这在我看来也相当晚。
Which was also fairly late. Yeah, sure. We're gradualists. We don't like to do anything extreme. And Margaret Atwood says that this is because it's so cold here and that you have to be so careful. You'd like to take your clothes off and go running outside, but it's so cold most of the time that you keep at least some of your clothes on, even though you're pretending to be naked.
这确实也相当晚。是的，当然。我们是渐进主义者。我们不喜欢做任何极端的事情。玛格丽特·阿特伍德说，这是因为这里太冷了，你必须非常小心。你可能想脱掉衣服出去跑步，但大部分时间太冷了，所以你至少会保留一些衣服，尽管你假装自己是赤裸的。
I was thinking about this the other day. And I was engaged in a little us-versus-them debate with a Canadian friend. And I was talking about the Declaration of Independence and the Constitution and words and phrases like "We, the people" and "life, liberty, pursuit of happiness," and how these things have had this enormous bearing on me, certainly as a writer, and being able to say what I think, and that it's codified within these governmental structures. And at one point, I just said, "what's your sound bite?" And he didn't have one. Is there a sound bite of Canadian-ness?
前几天我一直在想这个问题。我当时和一位加拿大朋友进行了一场小型的“我们与他们”的辩论。我谈到了《独立宣言》和宪法，以及“我们，人民”、“生命、自由、追求幸福”等词汇和短语，以及这些东西对我作为一个作家，以及能够表达我的想法，并将其编入这些政府结构中，产生了巨大的影响。在某个时候，我只是说，“你的口号是什么？”他没有。有“加拿大身份”的口号吗？
Well, I always liked "the True North, strong and free" myself. That's always appealed to me. And it's probably imported from somewhere. But that's always the one I like. And I think it's Voltaire's description of "a few acres of snow." I think he said that. I always liked that image.
嗯，我一直喜欢“真正的北方，强大而自由”。那一直吸引着我。它可能是从某个地方进口的。但那一直是我喜欢的。而且我想那是伏尔泰对“几英亩雪地”的描述。我想他是这么说的。我一直很喜欢那个意象。
"A few acres of snow." Doesn't that just make you want to go out and change the world?
“几英亩雪地”。那难道不会让你想出去改变世界吗？
No, what it does is it reminds you that this country-- far more than yours-- is a physical country. You folks have all these ideas-- or so-called ideas-- Manifest Destiny, the pursuit of happiness-- life, liberty, and the pursuit of happiness. But they're ideas. And physically, the country doesn't really exist. I was always amazed that more Americans aren't interested in politics down there. Your voting participation rate is absolutely abysmal. And I think it's because people can't conceive of the country in any way. It's like an amassing together of individualisms.
不，它提醒你的是，这个国家——远比你们的国家——是一个物理意义上的国家。你们这些人有所有这些想法——或者所谓的想法——昭昭天命、追求幸福——生命、自由和追求幸福。但它们只是想法。而在物理上，这个国家并不真正存在。我一直很惊讶，为什么更多的美国人对那里的政治不感兴趣。你们的投票参与率绝对糟糕透顶。我认为这是因为人们无法以任何方式构想这个国家。它就像是个体主义的汇聚。
But after a while, there's so many individualisms that there's nothing collective there. In some ways, Canada has exactly the opposite problem, that we've needed to be collective. And for so long, it's been impossible to be an individualist and still be a Canadian. But it has to do with how youthful the country is.
但过了一会儿，太多个体主义聚集在一起，就没有什么集体的东西了。在某些方面，加拿大有完全相反的问题，我们需要成为集体。而且很长一段时间以来，如果不放弃个体主义而成为加拿大人是不可能的。但这与这个国家的年轻程度有关。
I've been in the wilderness quite a bit in both Canada and the United States. And I always notice this incredible difference. In Canada, if I go-- I don't know-- 100 hundred miles north of Winnipeg, there are places where you go out into the bush, you go out into the wilderness, and you really do have this sense that you may very well be the first person to be standing there. That this is really virgin territory and you're standing there. And that's an incredible feeling, because--
我在加拿大和美国的荒野中待过不少时间。我总是注意到这种令人难以置信的差异。在加拿大，如果我去——我不知道——温尼伯以北100英里处，有些地方你进入丛林，进入荒野，你真的会有一种感觉，你很可能是第一个站在那里的人。这里真的是处女地，而你站在那里。那是一种令人难以置信的感觉，因为——
But I'm from Montana. We have that there too.
但我来自蒙大拿州。我们那里也有这种感觉。
But you don't have it the same way. I've been in Montana. I've been on the top of the Teton Mountains and all the rest. And you get up there, and the sensation you have in the American wilderness is, well, this is incredible because I'm standing where so many people have gone before. Lewis and Clark were here, blah, blah, blah, all these people. And I'm standing in their footsteps, and that is the great thing. Whereas in Canada, it's the exact opposite. No one was here. I'm the first person.
但你不是以同样的方式拥有它。我去过蒙大拿州。我去过大提顿山脉的顶峰等等。你到了那里，你在美国荒野中拥有的感觉是，嗯，这太不可思议了，因为我站在很多人曾经去过的地方。刘易斯和克拉克曾在这里，诸如此类，所有人。我站在他们的足迹中，那是伟大的事情。而在加拿大，情况恰恰相反。没有人来过这里。我是第一个人。
And it has real consequences. In America, the great thing you have is your history and your tradition. The hard thing in America these days it seems to me looking at it from afar, is that it's so hard to think, well, I can do something new. We can break out of the box we're in. Look at something like campaign reform. Nobody thinks you can ever fix it, so why the heck try? Whereas in Canada, we have exactly the opposite problem. We all think, well, I couldn't possibly do this because no one's ever been here or done this before. It really is like the invert of--
而且它有真正的后果。在美国，你拥有伟大的历史和传统。从远处看，美国这些日子困难的是，很难想到，“好吧，我可以做些新的事情。”我们可以打破我们所处的框框。看看竞选改革之类的东西。没人认为你能解决它，所以为什么要费心尝试？而在加拿大，我们有完全相反的问题。我们都想，“好吧，我不可能这样做，因为从来没有人来过这里或做过这件事。”这真的就像是——的倒置。
Well, you're right, except the very idea of America is that even though tons of people have been there, done that, the idea of America is that you don't care. You just keep going.
好吧，你是对的，除了美国的整个理念是，即使有成吨的人去过、做过那件事，美国的理念是你不关心。你只是继续前进。
Yeah, but you've got to be more and more outlandish, it seems to us. The fact that Jerry Springer comes from your country is--
是的，但你必须越来越古怪，在我们看来。杰瑞·斯普林格来自你们的国家这个事实是——
Oh, thanks for bringing that up.
噢，谢谢你提起那件事。
Well, I'm sorry, but how does he fit into Manifest Destiny? If that's the end result of it--
好吧，我很抱歉，但他怎么符合昭昭天命？如果那是它的最终结果——
Well, we have to take the agony with the ecstasy.
好吧，我们必须在苦难中忍受狂喜。
Well, that's what makes your country so interesting. And I think that's why people stereotype Canada and say it's boring. They think there is no individual spirit here. Wrongly, of course, but they do think that. And we think all you've got is yakking.
好吧，这就是让你们国家如此有趣的原因。我认为这就是为什么人们给加拿大贴上标签并认为它很无聊的原因。他们认为这里没有个人精神。当然是错的，但他们确实这么认为。而我们认为你们所拥有的只是吹牛。
Well, that's interesting for someone who yaks for a living to say.
嗯，对于一个靠吹牛谋生的人来说，这很有趣。
Admittedly. Well, I have an American wife, remember.
无可否认。好吧，记住，我有一个美国妻子。
That's right. Well, we won't hold that against you.
没错。好吧，我们不会因为那个而针对你。
No, but the Canadians hold it against her. She often complains. She says there is a distinct anti-American feeling here. And she's a lovely person, and people like her. But she says people are always saying at parties, oh, that's so American, when someone talks about somebody being crass or somebody being particularly ambitious or particularly in your face. They say, oh, that's so American. Then they remember she's American and they say, oh, sorry, Johanna, not you. You're different.
不，但加拿大人针对她。她经常抱怨。她说这里有一种明显的反美情绪。她是一个可爱的人，人们喜欢她。但她说人们在聚会上总是说，“噢，那太美国了”，当有人谈论某人很粗俗或某人特别雄心勃勃或特别咄咄逼人时。他们说，“噢，那太美国了。”然后他们想起她是美国人，就说，“噢，对不起，乔安娜，不是你。你是不同的。”
And she thinks it's quite widespread. And I will say that as a Canadian, I never noticed anything like that down in America. It is a very, very, very tolerant place until you stand up and say, well, Canadians are different. And then they say, oh, no you're not. You're exactly the same. You like Disney too, don't you? And we say, well, yeah we do, but not all the time.
她认为这很普遍。我不得不说，作为一个加拿大人，我在美国从未注意到类似的事情。那是一个非常、非常、非常宽容的地方，直到你站出来说，“嗯，加拿大人是不同的。”然后他们说，“噢，不，你们不是。你们完全一样。你也喜欢迪士尼，不是吗？”我们说，“嗯，是的，我们喜欢，但不是一直。”
Can you recall one of those particular moments where you felt like an alien or you felt like an American did or said something that seemed completely foreign to you?
你能想起那些你觉得自己像个外星人，或者你觉得美国人做或说了一些在你看来完全陌生的话的特定时刻吗？
I was walking along the boardwalk of Manhattan Beach in California. Manhattan Beach is right on the water, and there's this beautiful-- I was walking along, and I was having an argument with my wife. Not a loud argument, but an argument. A debate, I guess you could call it. And we were debating the merits of speaking in front of our children-- in front of my daughter-- and having discussions as if she wasn't there.
我走在加利福尼亚州曼哈顿海滩的木板路上。曼哈顿海滩就在水边，这里很美——我走着走着，和我妻子争论。不是大声争论，但争论。辩论，我想你可以这么称呼它。我们正在辩论在孩子面前说话的优点——在我的女儿面前——而且假装她不在场进行讨论。
And as we were walking along, some guy on rollerblades went by and looked at us. And then he turned around, he came back up to me, and he said, "Man, I want to tell you, man, it, like, really lays some heavy lumber"-- I don't think he said lumber, but-- "it lays some heavy groove on your kids, man, to be fighting in front of them." And I said, "Well, first of all, we weren't fighting. We were having a debate. And B, it's none of your business. Get out of my face." That would never happen.
当我们走着的时候，一个溜冰的人经过并看着我们。然后他转过身来，走到我身边，他说，“伙计，我想告诉你，伙计，在孩子面前打架，真的对他们造成了严重的心理阴影，伙计。”我说，“好吧，首先，我们没有打架。我们是在进行辩论。而且，B，这不关你的事。离我远点。”那是永远不会发生的。
You don't have jerks in Canada?
你们加拿大没有混蛋吗？
It's not jerks. I mean, he probably had a point. But no Canadian that I have ever encountered would ever deign to even come close to telling you how-- especially publicly. Especially publicly.
不是混蛋。我的意思是，他可能有道理。但据我所知，没有一个加拿大人会屈尊到甚至接近于告诉你怎么做——尤其是在公共场合。尤其是公共场合。
Well, it seems like the things that you've been bringing up-- these differences-- are rather confined to the sphere of minutiae. I mean, are the two cultures really separate? Can you separate them?
好吧，似乎你提到的那些事情——这些差异——相当局限于琐事的范畴。我的意思是，这两种文化真的是分开的吗？你能把它们分开吗？
I understand your question, and there are so many similarities that many Canadians ask much the same question. We live in a global world, it's a global economy, we're all the same, nationalism is for jerks. But civically, we're very different. We have a parliamentary democracy here. There are at least two, and possibly more, parties involved in every single debate. Everything is voted on.
我明白你的问题，而且有太多的相似之处，许多加拿大人问过同样的问题。我们生活在一个全球化的世界，这是一个全球经济，我们都是一样的，民族主义是为混蛋准备的。但在公民层面，我们非常不同。我们这里有议会民主制。每次辩论中至少有两个，甚至可能更多，政党参与。所有事情都要投票。
We elect our representatives directly to the House of Commons. Our prime minister is chosen from amongst them, generally speaking. That's not the case in America. You have this complicated checks and balances system, which seems to us to have no direct representation at all. And judging from the fractions in which you vote, a lot of Americans feel the same way, too. Whereas in Canada, voter participation is pretty high.
我们直接选举我们的代表进入下议院。我们的总理通常是从他们中间选出的。在美国情况并非如此。你们有这个复杂的制衡系统，在我们看来，根本没有直接代表权。从你们投票的分数来看，很多美国人也有同感。而在加拿大，选民参与度很高。
But besides these political differences, how-- for instance, we've been having these conversations around here in planning this show where someone says, Neil Young-- Canadian. Everyone says, he's Canadian? Or Mike Myers or Pamela Anderson Lee. You know, the blond bimbo babe of all time-- Canadian.
但除了这些政治差异，如何——例如，我们在计划这个节目时，周围一直在进行这些对话，有人说，尼尔·杨——加拿大人。每个人都说，他是加拿大人？或者麦克·迈尔斯或帕梅拉·安德森·李。你知道，有史以来最金发的胸大无脑的宝贝——加拿大人。
They can't believe she's Canadian?
他们不敢相信她是加拿大人？
Canadian, yeah. It always ends the same way. And it seems like despite these small, little differences, or even huge political ones, it's really hard to tell an American and a Canadian apart.
加拿大人，是的。它总是以同样的方式结束。看来，尽管有这些小小的微小差异，甚至巨大的政治差异，真的很难分辨美国人和加拿大人。
Well, it depends how you measure them, though. Neil Armstrong is a great-- Neil Armstrong. He was American, right? He's the first guy who ever-- and he's American. It's incredible! No, Neil Young-- he's a brilliant songwriter and musician, so he hits the universal in that way.
嗯，这取决于你如何衡量他们。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗是一个伟大的——尼尔·阿姆斯特朗。他是美国人，对吧？他是第一个曾经——而且他是美国人。这太不可思议了！不，尼尔·杨——他是一位才华横溢的词曲作者和音乐家，所以他以那种方式触及了普遍性。
Yeah, but he wrote my favorite song, "Keep on Rockin' in the Free World," which is, to me, maybe one of the most American songs. It has this incredible beat, it rocks, it's a condemnation specifically of the Bush administration, but it's also about hope and imagination as well as Styrofoam and the ozone layer. To me, it's an American song.
是的，但他写了我最喜欢的歌，“继续在自由世界摇滚”，对我来说，这可能是最美国的歌曲之一。它有这种令人难以置信的节拍，它摇滚，它是对布什政府的具体谴责，但它也是关于希望和想象力，以及泡沫塑料和臭氧层。对我来说，这是一首美国歌曲。
Well, that's, I think, you defining the song. It's not Neil defining the song. One of my favorite songs of his begins, "There is a town in North Ontario." I'd say that's the emblematic Neil Young song. And to me, he's hugely Canadian. Not only is he hugely Canadian because he writes the songs he does, because so many of them have a northern, isolated feel to them, because they are about strong emotion expressed quietly and expressed in a quiet vessel but also because his dad was a sportswriter for The Globe and Mail who everybody read. So I can't separate him out.
好吧，我认为那是你定义了这首歌。不是尼尔定义了这首歌。他最喜欢的歌曲之一开头是，“北安大略省有一个小镇。”我会说那是尼尔·杨的标志性歌曲。对我来说，他非常有加拿大特色。不仅因为他写了那些歌，因为其中许多都有北方、孤立的感觉，因为它们是关于在安静的容器中安静地表达的强烈情感，而且还因为他的父亲是《环球邮报》的体育记者，每个人都读他的报道。所以我无法将他分开。
OK, what about Pamela Anderson Lee, then?
OK，那帕梅拉·安德森·李呢？
Well, as I say, we're talking about the universal here, aren't we? You know what they say. If you want to sell something to everybody, make sure it has a large bust line. So she feels that--
嗯，正如我所说，我们在谈论普遍性，不是吗？你知道他们怎么说。如果你想把东西卖给所有人，确保它有一个巨大的胸围。所以她感觉到了——
They say that?
他们那么说？
Marketers sometimes say that. What is she? She's like the most universally pneumatic vacuum in the world. So it's true. That doesn't feel particularly Canadian. And I understand why. But she's not a serious example. She's a woman--
营销人员有时这么说。她是什么？她就像世界上最普遍的气动真空。所以这是真的。那感觉不特别加拿大。我明白为什么。但她不是一个严肃的例子。她是一个女人——
You only want the serious people? You only want to claim Neil Young?
你只想要严肃的人？你只想要尼尔·杨？
I only want to talk about the ones that you can actually measure on a real basis. I don't know what Pamela Lee was before she was inflated. But I'd be willing to say the old, uninflated Pamela Lee, before she became almost the quintessential Hollywood bombshell, I'll bet you could find Canadian stuff about her. I don't know. It would be an interesting story. That's for sure.
我只想谈论那些你可以在真实基础上衡量的。我不知道帕梅拉·李在被注入填充物之前是什么。但我敢打赌，你可以找到关于她加拿大的一面。我不知道。那将是一个有趣的故事。那是肯定的。
And is the plastic surgery-- is it that part of her is now physically American?
而且整形手术——那是她现在身体上美国化的那部分吗？
That is definitely American. Oh, absolutely. Yeah. That part of Pamela Lee is as American as American goes.
那是绝对美国化的。噢，当然。是的。帕梅拉·李的那部分就像美国人一样美国化。
I know that you're running out of time. If not, you're out of time on your end. But I just want to ask before we end, what was your favorite thing about being a Canadian living in the US when you did?
我知道你的时间快到了。如果没有，你的时间也到了。但我只是想在结束前问一下，你作为加拿大人在美国生活时，你最喜欢的一件事是什么？
Americans. Americans. Because I work as a writer. And in Canada, one of the biggest parts of the job is to draw people out, to make them comfortable, to get them talking, to get them to realize that it's just a conversation, that they can be themselves. Americans are much less conscious of themselves. They have much less self-consciousness. They're much more themselves in the world. And damn it if you don't like it. I'm an American. I'm an individual.
美国人。美国人。因为我是一个作家。在加拿大，工作中最大的一部分是引导人们，让他们感到舒适，让他们交谈，让他们意识到这只是一个对话，他们可以成为他们自己。美国人对自己比较少关注。他们有较少的自我意识。他们在世界上更像他们自己。如果你不喜欢它，该死。我是美国人。我是一个个体。
And so you get all this incredible unconscious behavior happening right in front you. It's like having your own little stage show wherever you go. There's always some entertainment because there's always people being themselves. You don't get that as much in Canada. And I found it--
所以你就在你面前发生了所有这些令人难以置信的潜意识行为。这就像无论你去哪里都有你自己的小舞台表演。总会有一些娱乐，因为总有人成为他们自己。你在加拿大没那么常遇到这种情况。我发现它——
Do we amuse you?
我们逗你乐吗？
No, I don't mean in a condescending way. I'm glad I'm not of it, but I love having a seat ringside.
不，我不是指以一种屈尊的方式。我很高兴我不是其中的一部分，但我喜欢在场边有一个座位。
Ian Brown with This American Life contributing editor Sarah Vowell, author of the book Take the Cannoli.
伊恩·布朗与《美国生活》特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔，书籍《带上卡诺里》的作者。
[MUSIC - "ROCKIN' IN THE FREE WORLD" BY NEIL YOUNG]
[音乐——尼尔·杨的“在自由世界摇滚”]
Coming up, the secret pro-Canadian messages in Peter Jennings' nightly newscast and more, in a minute, when our program continues.
即将到来，彼得·詹宁斯每晚新闻中的秘密亲加拿大信息，等等，在一分钟内，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Who's Canadian? Stories of the Canadians among us. We've arrived at Act Three, Outing.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来关于那个主题的各种不同类型的故事。今天的节目，“谁是加拿大人？”我们身边的加拿大人故事。我们已经到达第三幕，出柜。
Well, the Canadian on the This American Life staff, Paul Tough, tells this story about watching the movie Wayne's World . There's a scene in Wayne's World where one of the stars and writers of the film, Mike Myers, and his buddies in the movie, allegedly portraying American teenagers, play street hockey.
好吧，《美国生活》的加拿大人员工保罗·塔夫，讲述了这个观看电影《韦恩的世界》的故事。在《韦恩的世界》中有一个场景，其中一位明星和编剧迈克·迈尔斯，以及他在电影中的好友，据称是描绘美国青少年，玩街头曲棍球。
They're doing what a lot of Canadians do and what I certainly did as a Canadian youth, which is they're playing on the street. They have nets set up on the street. They're playing with a tennis ball and hockey sticks. And the goalies are all in equipment. And when a car comes down the street, the first person to see the car yells, car! And everyone just stops the game and grabs the nets and gets to the side of the street. And then when the car passes, they say, game on! And they start playing again.
他们做着很多加拿大人做的事情，以及我作为一个加拿大青年肯定做的事情，那就是他们在街上玩。他们在街上架起球网。他们用网球和曲棍球棍玩。守门员都穿着装备。当一辆车驶过街道时，第一个看到车的人大喊，“车！”每个人只是停止游戏，抓住网，跑到街边。然后当车经过时，他们说，“游戏继续！”然后他们重新开始游戏。
And when I saw that, it was like it was a secret message from Mike Myers to me and all the other Canadians who were watching this movie in the American audience, because those were exactly the two phrases that we would use. And no American knows those phrases. And Mike Myers, of course, growing up in [? Otobaco, ?] the true Wayne's World, grew up playing road hockey just like I did. And the sad thing is, he couldn't set his movie in Canada because then it would've been a Canadian movie, even if it was exactly the same movie. It was about Canadian culture, but in order to pass he had to set it in Illinois.
当我看到那个场景时，就好像它是迈克·迈尔斯给我和所有在美国观众中看这部电影的其他加拿大人的一条秘密信息，因为那正是我们会用的那两个短语。而且没有美国人知道那些短语。迈克·迈尔斯，当然，在[奥托巴科]长大，真正的《韦恩的世界》，长大后就像我一样玩公路曲棍球。悲哀的是，他不能把电影设置在加拿大，因为那样它就会是一部加拿大电影，即使它是完全一样的电影。它是关于加拿大文化的，但为了通过，他必须把它设置在伊利诺伊州。
Canadians, of course, are everywhere in the American media, from Lorne Michaels to Alanis Morissette. Well, the question we ask in this act of our program is this. When Canadians rise to the top of American pop culture, the American media machine, once they have America's attention, what do they decide to do with it?
加拿大人，当然，在美国媒体中随处可见，从洛恩·迈克尔斯到艾拉妮丝·莫莉塞特。好吧，我们在节目这一幕中问的问题是这个。当加拿大人上升到美国流行文化的顶端，美国媒体机器，一旦他们获得了美国的注意力，他们决定用它做什么？
To answer this question, let's examine first a show that, on first glance, seems quintessentially American, could not get more American, Beverly Hills 90210. Danny Drennan writes the entertaining and definitive 90210 Weekly Wrapup on the world wide web. He argues that 90210 is a kind of Canadian Trojan horse.
为了回答这个问题，让我们首先检查一个乍看之下似乎非常典型的美国节目，不可能更美国了，《飞越比弗利》。丹尼·德雷南在万维网上写了娱乐性和权威性的《90210周刊综述》。他认为90210是一种加拿大特洛伊木马。
The show is based on a Canadian TV series called Degrassi High . Some characters and storylines are lifted straight from the original series. Not one but two Canadians star on the show, Kathleen Robertson and Jason Priestley. And Priestley has slowly risen from actor to director and producer of the show. Once Priestley had control of storylines and content, yes, the inevitable happens.
该节目基于一个名为《迪格拉西中学》的加拿大电视剧。一些角色和故事情节直接从原系列中提取。不是一个，而是两个加拿大人在节目中担任主演，凯瑟琳·罗伯逊和杰森·普雷斯利。而普雷斯利已经慢慢从演员上升为节目的导演和制片人。一旦普雷斯利控制了故事情节和内容，是的，不可避免的事情发生了。
Canadian references start to show up in 90210 in various guises. One episode sees Steve, Brandon, and Joe meeting some girls from Canada. And Jason's character, Brandon Walsh, unnecessarily comments on where they are from, Parry Sound, home of Hall of Fame hockey player Bobby Orr. Who even remembers who Bobby Orr is, much less where he was born? Brandon's later comment as he ogles the girls from afar is, "O, Canada." When their girlfriends get jealous, Brandon is like, we just got totally hosed, eh?
加拿大参考开始以各种伪装出现在90210中。在一集中，史蒂夫、布兰登和乔遇到了来自加拿大的女孩。杰森的角色，布兰登·沃尔什，不必要地评论她们来自哪里，帕里桑德，名人堂曲棍球运动员鲍比·奥尔的家。谁还记得鲍比·奥尔是谁，更不用说他出生在哪里？布兰登后来从远处窥视女孩时的评论是，“噢，加拿大。”当他们的女朋友嫉妒时，布兰登就像，“我们刚刚被彻底洗劫了，啊？”
In one episode, for no reason whatsoever, Brandon refers to Manitoba. In the season finale, Steve makes the throwaway statement that his American actress mother is doing theater in Toronto. In yet another, Kathleen Robertson's character, Clare Arnold, called Steve a hoser. Clare is often heard gratuitously attempting to speak mangled French, like the time when she wanted to say, "let the best man win." In French, "que le meilleur gagne," which instead came out "culla mello gong," in what I can only imagine is a shout-out to Quebec or something.
在一集中，布兰登毫无理由地提到了曼尼托巴省。在季末大结局中，史蒂夫随口说出他的美国女演员母亲正在多伦多演戏。在另一集中，凯瑟琳·罗伯逊的角色，克莱尔·阿诺德，称史蒂夫为“hozer”。克莱尔经常被听到试图免费说蹩脚的法语，比如她想说“让最优秀的人获胜”的时候。在法语中，“que le meilleur gagne”，这反而变成了“culla mello gong”，我想象这是对魁北克或什么的呐喊。
Brandon, in one show, plays in a charity hockey tournament with guest stars Cam Neely and Ron Duguay.
布兰登在一场节目中与客串明星凯姆·尼利和罗恩·杜盖一起参加了慈善曲棍球比赛。
You must've got a few splinters from your stick in my jersey.
你一定从你的棍子上在我球衣上得到了一些碎片。
Maybe you're too fast for your own good.
也许你太快了，对自己没好处。
I think you may want to pick up your jock strap. You left it back there by the blue line.
我想你可能想捡起你的护裆。你把它留在蓝线后面了。
This is going to be fun playing with you all.
和你们所有人一起玩会很有趣。
Could someone please tell me who plays hockey in Los Angeles? The fact is that in real life, Priestley used to play center on a Division II hockey team where his teammate was Michael J. Fox. It's all connected.
有人能告诉我谁在洛杉矶玩曲棍球吗？事实是，在现实生活中，普雷斯利过去在二级曲棍球队担任中锋，他的队友是迈克尔·J·福克斯。这一切都是连接起来的。
Then there was the show that starts out with an extreme close-up shot of a maple leaf insignia on the back of Brandon's shirt for, like, two minutes before Brandon walks away. The show basically starts out displaying the Canadian flag. I mean, aren't there FCC laws against this kind of thing?
然后是那个节目，以布兰登衬衫背面的枫叶徽章的极端特写镜头开始，持续了大约两分钟，然后布兰登走开。节目基本上是以展示加拿大国旗开始的。我的意思是，FCC难道没有关于这种事情的法律吗？
Another show featured a Ukrainian dance troupe, which is a stealth reference to Canada where such dance troupes are well known. Alex Trebek, former host of the Canadian show Stars on Ice and current host of Jeopardy! , which makes unwarranted reference to Canada more often than can be explained statistically, himself stars in a Jeopardy! dream sequence on 90210 .
另一个节目特色是一个乌克兰舞蹈团，这是对加拿大的隐秘参考，那里的这种舞蹈团非常有名。亚历克斯·特雷贝克，加拿大节目《冰上明星》的前主持人，《危险边缘》的现任主持人，该节目提到加拿大的频率往往比统计学上可以解释的要多，他自己在90210中主演了一个《危险边缘》的梦境序列。
Most recently, during a school talent show, Donna and Steve recreate a scene reminiscent of the Nelson Eddy- Jeanette MacDonald operetta-based movies of the '30s and '40s, in this case, featuring a Canadian Mountie and his gal singing "Royal Canadian Love Affair." A great cultural reference for Canadians. I mean, at least give the American audience a clue as to what you're talking about by mentioning Dudley Do-Right or something.
最近，在学校才艺表演期间，唐娜和史蒂夫重现了一个让人想起30年代和40年代尼尔森·艾迪-珍妮特·麦克唐纳轻歌剧电影的场景，在这种情况下，特色是一个加拿大皇家骑警和他的女孩唱“加拿大皇家爱情故事”。这对加拿大人来说是一个伟大的文化参考。我的意思是，至少给美国观众一点提示，通过提到达德利·Do-Right或什么的来让他们知道你在谈论什么。
Adding insult to injury, because of hockey playoffs, and unlike every other American-made entertainment product, 90210 is often seen on Monday night in Canada, two days before the Wednesday broadcast in the United States. Canadian friends and fellow viewers of the show have informed me that hoards of Canadians cheer as these Canadian references to the revolution are broadcast over the American airwaves. How did we ever reach this point?
雪上加霜的是，因为曲棍球季后赛，而且不像其他任何美国制造的娱乐产品，90210通常在星期一晚上在加拿大看到，比在美国的星期三广播早两天。加拿大朋友和节目的观众告知我，成群的加拿大人在这些对革命的加拿大参考在广播上播放时欢呼。我们是怎么走到这一步的？
Well, how indeed. Danny Drenna of the 90210 Weekly Wrapup and the forthcoming book, New York Diaries .
嗯，确实是如何。90210周刊综述的丹尼·德雷纳，以及即将出版的书《纽约日记》。
Our own contributing editor, Jack Hitt, has another searing expose on these strangers in our midst. He's been keeping tabs on Canadian Peter Jennings, host of ABC World News Tonight .
我们自己的特约编辑，杰克·希特，有另一篇关于我们中间这些陌生人的深刻揭露。他一直盯着加拿大彼得·詹宁斯，ABC世界新闻今晚的主持人。
It goes without saying that Peter Jennings is a mole, a spy, a shill, a confederate for Canada. All you have to do is watch his program, as I did one week.
毋庸置疑，彼得·詹宁斯是一个鼹鼠、一个间谍、一个托儿、一个加拿大的同伙。你所要做的就是看他的节目，像我一周所做的那样。
In Costa Rica today, President Clinton went to the rainforest, and he got wet.
今天在哥斯达黎加，克林顿总统去了雨林，他湿透了。
He's not liberal or conservative. Jennings just seems to have it in for the American government. Sometimes his reference is implied, even bizarre.
他不是自由派或保守派。詹宁斯只是似乎对美国政府有意见。有时他的参考是隐含的，甚至离奇。
The Pentagon does say today it is very concerned about an incident involving the Russians. Last month off the coast of Washington State, it appears that a Russian merchant ship directed a laser beam at a Canadian military helicopter carrying a US naval intelligence officer. He and a Canadian crew member both had their eyes burned, though not badly. The Russian ship was apparently monitoring American submarines in the region. The helicopter was monitoring the Russians.
五角大楼今天确实说它非常关注涉及俄罗斯人的一起事件。上个月在华盛顿州海岸外，似乎一艘俄罗斯商船将激光束对准了一架载有美国海军情报官员的加拿大军用直升机。他和一名加拿大机组成员的眼睛都被烧伤了，尽管并不严重。这艘俄罗斯船显然在监测该地区的美国潜艇。直升机在监测俄罗斯人。
What are we being told by this story? It's not easy to parse, but it's either about an innocent Canadian blinded by our defense obsession or the superior maturity of Canada for not being directly involved in the two superpowers' now admittedly absurd arms race. So there's no question about where Peter's loyalties lie. In fact, Peter wants to come out of the Canadian closet. His Freudian slips cry out.
这个故事告诉了我们什么？很难解析，但它要么是关于一个被我们的防御痴迷所致盲的无辜加拿大人，要么是关于加拿大没有直接卷入两个超级大国现在公认荒谬的军备竞赛的卓越成熟度。所以毫无疑问彼得的忠诚在哪里。事实上，彼得想从加拿大壁橱里出来。他的弗洛伊德式的口误在呐喊。
When we come back out-- or when we come back--
当我们回来时——或者当我们回来时——
Reckon you mean when you come back oot, don't you, stranger? Do you hear how Peter strains to split the difference between the Canadian oot and the American out? Listen again.
我想你的意思是当你回来时，对吧，陌生人？你听到彼得是如何努力在加拿大发音和美国发音之间分割差异的吗？再听一遍。
When we come back out-- or when we come back--
当我们回来时——或者当我们回来时——
You'll notice that Peter's always about to come back from somewhere.
你会注意到彼得总是要从某个地方回来。
When we come back, the stunning drop in the welfare rolls.
当我们回来时，福利名单的惊人下降。
When we come back, the space-age technology that is already down on the farm.
当我们回来时，农场上已经拥有的太空时代技术。
When we come back, your money--
当我们回来时，你的钱——
Or he's heading out.
或者他要出去了。
We're going to begin tonight with an--
我们要从今晚开始——
Or he's inviting us somewhere.
或者他正在邀请我们去某个地方。
Finally this evening, we're going to take you to Alabama.
今晚最后，我们将带你去阿拉巴马州。
See, Peter's on a journey to someplace. If you watch his show long enough, it's obvious. The very structure of the show has a sense that we're going somewhere-- a place, a mythical place. Every program has this feeling of zigzagging en route to some ultimate destination. And you know where he wants to take us? Canada. That's right, Canada.
看，彼得正在前往某处的旅程中。如果你看他的节目足够久，很明显。节目的整个结构有一种我们要去某个地方的感觉——一个地方，一个神话般的地方。每个节目都有这种在前往最终目的地途中曲折的感觉。而且你知道他想带我们去哪里吗？加拿大。没错，加拿大。
But actually, after you've watched World News Tonight long enough, you realize that this is not a journey to the real Canada but to the platonic ideal of Canadian-ness. Stay with me here. See, Peter's news is noticeably different from Dan Rather and Tom Brokaw's. Tom and Dan see a hostile world erupting with bad news everywhere, full of murder and mayhem, macho and dismal, hell in a hand basket, fire and brimstone stuff. You know, very puritanical, very American in outlook.
但实际上，在你看了足够久的《世界新闻今晚》之后，你意识到这不是前往真实加拿大的旅程，而是前往加拿大身份的柏拉图式理想的旅程。跟我来。看，彼得的新闻与丹·拉瑟和汤姆·布罗考的新闻明显不同。汤姆和丹看到一个充满坏消息的敌对世界，到处都是谋杀和骚乱，大男子主义和阴郁，地狱在手提篮中，火和硫磺的东西。你知道，非常清教徒，非常美国化的视角。
Dan's all clenched jaws, garretted coat and tie, a human time bomb waiting to explode. Peter's just kicking back. He could be wearing a smoking jacket and, during the commercial, sipping a mild single-malt Scotch. Once Peter gets past ridiculing the American government, it's odd, but suddenly, the news he's reading is uncannily bright. Cheerful and good news. Healing news. Soothing news. Ecumenical news. Canadian news.
丹是紧握的下巴，束紧的外套和领带，一颗随时准备爆炸的人体定时炸弹。彼得只是在放松。他可能穿着一件吸烟夹克，在广告期间，啜饮着温和的单一麦芽苏格兰威士忌。一旦彼得超过了嘲笑美国政府的阶段，这很奇怪，但突然间，他读的新闻出奇地明亮。开朗和好消息。治愈新闻。抚慰新闻。普世新闻。加拿大新闻。
They've approved a new type of laser device that should permit a dentist to fill a tooth more efficiently, and for you, if you have to go, maybe more comfortably, as well.
他们批准了一种新型激光设备，应该允许牙医更有效地补牙，而对于你，如果你必须去，也许更舒服。
More comfortable dentistry. My, that is good news. But wait.
更舒适的牙科。天哪，那真是好消息。但等等。
You may soon be able to check for E. coli bacteria right in the supermarket.
你可能很快就能在超市检查大肠杆菌细菌。
No more food poisoning. Terrific.
不再食物中毒。太棒了。
The new obesity pill that actually breaks down fat in the body.
实际上能分解体内脂肪的新型减肥药。
To understand the real meaning of this Canadian news, one has to read past the literal facts embedded in each statement and get to the level on which television actually speaks to us-- emotion. To really feel it, you have to merge the ads and the news into one seamless half hour of Peterphoria. You have to step a bit further back from the screen, lie down on a down comforter, and let it wash over you, like reading Finnegans Wake .
要理解这则加拿大新闻的真正意义，必须读出嵌入在每项陈述中的字面事实，并达到电视实际与我们交谈的层面——情感。要真正感觉到它，你必须将广告和新闻合并成半小时无缝的“彼得狂喜”。你必须从屏幕后退一点，躺在羽绒被上，让它洗刷你，就像读《芬尼根守灵夜》一样。
And if you do this, suddenly the hidden meaning becomes instantaneously clear and weirdly repetitive. The message is, surrender. Your time is over. My fellow Americans, a great nation is being asked to lie down and give it up. Peter's meaning is clear. Even superpowers must age and yield and settle down. One ad that airs a couple of times every show is for SunAmerica. Sun, as in setting sun.
如果你这样做，突然间隐藏的含义变得瞬间清晰且奇怪地重复。信息是，投降。你的时间到了。我的美国同胞，一个伟大的国家被要求躺下并放弃它。彼得的意思很清楚。即使是超级大国也必须变老、屈服并安定下来。一个在每个节目播出几次的广告是为SunAmerica准备的。Sun，如同落日。
SunAmerica. Ask about our personal retirement portfolios. SunAmerica, the retirement specialists.
SunAmerica。询问我们的个人退休投资组合。SunAmerica，退休专家。
Retire. No commercial break passes without the word reverberating through the screen. But of course, Peter and his fellow travelers try to keep this message lively and vibrant.
退休。没有广告中断不伴随这个词在屏幕中回荡。但当然，彼得和他的同伴们试图让这个信息保持活跃和充满活力。
[MUSIC PLAYING] You did your job. You did it well.
[音乐播放] 你完成了你的工作。你做得很好。
It's OK, see? Over time though, the message goes even further than that. Why just retire? Even the musical score begins to hint at the next logical option.
没关系，看吧？随着时间的推移，信息甚至走得更远。为什么要退休？即使是乐谱也开始暗示下一个逻辑选项。
Tum-tum-tum-tum, Tums.
Tum-tum-tum-tum，Tums。
I don't think I'm stretching here. You heard it yourself. The message is, let it go. Cross all the way over to the other side. The entire half hour is a kind of advertisement for dark eternity.
我不认为我在延伸。你亲自听到了。信息是，放手。完全越过到另一边。整个半小时是一种对黑暗永恒的广告。
Sometimes you have to tell yourself, stop. Look around. This is the good stuff.
有时你必须告诉自己，停下来。四处看看。这是好东西。
[SINGING] The look, the feel of cotton, the fabric of our lives.
[唱歌] 棉花的外观和感觉，我们生活的面料。
This is cotton.
这是棉花。
This is cotton? Honey, this is a shroud. Just when is it that you stop living and look around? We're dying here. See how obvious it is once you take off your rose-colored glasses and see what's in front of your face? Once you tune in at this level-- the real level-- each commercial gets increasingly more frightening.
这是棉花？亲爱的，这是一个裹尸布。你到底什么时候停止生活并四处看看？我们死在这里了。当你摘下有色眼镜并看到眼前的东西时，这有多明显？一旦你在这个层面调入——真正的层面——每个广告都变得越来越可怕。
Wouldn't you like to go someplace that felt really safe and secure? Well, now you can.
你不想去一个感觉非常安全和可靠的地方吗？好吧，现在你可以了。
Someplace safe and secure. Someplace like America, but without all those tense Dan Rather troubles. Someplace like Canada. And isn't that how Americans have always thought of Canada? It's like America, only without any jazz. Tranquil and safe and secure and endless, like death. If only Peter can take us to that place where we no longer have any anxiety. If only Peter can remove the sting. If only Peter can end the fear. If only.
某个安全和可靠的地方。某个像美国一样的地方，但没有所有那些紧张的丹·拉瑟的麻烦。某个像加拿大一样的地方。这难道不是美国人一直认为加拿大是的样子吗？它就像美国，只是没有任何爵士乐。平静、安全、可靠且无尽，就像死亡一样。如果彼得能带我们去那个我们不再有任何焦虑的地方。如果彼得能消除刺痛。如果彼得能结束恐惧。如果。
When we come back out-- or when we come back-- taking the anxiety out of the fear.
当我们回来时——或者当我们回来时——把焦虑从恐惧中消除。
Uh huh. Take us out, Peter. Tell us what the story is all aboot.
嗯哼。带我们出去，彼得。告诉我们故事到底是什么。
Today, the story that reminds us once again that things are not always what they appear to be.
今天，这个故事再次提醒我们，事情并不总是它们看起来的样子。
Jack Hitt.
杰克·希特。
Act Four, Who's Canadian? Another story of siblings parted ways. Our senior editor Paul Tough and his sister grew up in Toronto, the most American of Canadian cities. Then, about 10 years ago, they both left and headed in opposite directions. He moved to New York City, where he's lived ever since. She began a series of moves to smaller, more typically Canadian cities and towns. In Paul's view, she is the good Canadian. He's the bad one.
第四幕，“谁是加拿大人？”另一个兄妹分道扬镳的故事。我们的高级编辑保罗·塔夫和他的妹妹在多伦多长大，这是最美国化的加拿大城市。然后，大约10年前，他们都离开了，朝着相反的方向前进。他搬到了纽约市，从那时起一直住在那里。她开始了一系列搬到更小、更典型的加拿大城市和城镇。在保罗看来，她是好加拿大人。他是坏的一个。
All this hour, we've heard people talk about who's Canadian and what it means to be a Canadian. We asked Paul to call his sister and find out whether she still considers him to be a Canadian.
在这一小时里，我们听到了人们讨论谁是加拿大人以及身为加拿大人意味着什么。我们让保罗打电话给他的妹妹，看看她是否仍然认为他是加拿大人。
It's not just that my sister actually lives in Canada, and right in the heart of the country where it's winter for eight months out of the year, that makes me think of her as the quintessential Canadian. And it's not even her ideas about the place or her sense of patriotism. It's more the way that she lives in Canada, connected to her small community and her neighbors and the natural world around her, working at her church and in her kitchen and in her garden. That, to me, is a Canadian life. And from my studio apartment in New York, her life in Winnipeg seems very far away. And I think to her, I seem far away, too.
不仅是我妹妹实际上住在加拿大，而且就在国家的心脏地带，那里一年有八个月是冬天，这让我认为她是典型的加拿大人。甚至不是她对这个地方的想法或她的爱国感。更多的是她住在加拿大的方式，与她的小社区和她的邻居以及她周围的自然世界相连，在她教堂、厨房和花园里工作。对我来说，那是加拿大的生活。从我在纽约的公寓，她在温尼伯的生活似乎非常遥远。而且我认为对她来说，我也显得很遥远。
It's interesting because I talk about you often when I talk to people. And I talk about you as being my brother who has gone off and lived in the United States. And I talk about you with a great deal of pride. And people certainly respond by being very impressed. But there's that sense in which-- so I was thinking, if you came here, you would be a celebrity in the sense that you're my brother who lives in the United States and you live this highly sophisticated life and you live in New York City and everyone's deeply impressed by this.
这很有趣，因为当我与人交谈时，我经常谈论你。我谈论你作为我的兄弟，已经离开并住在美国。我怀着极大的自豪谈论你。人们当然通过感到非常深刻来回应。但有一种意义在于——所以我当时在想，如果你来这里，你会是一个名人，在这个意义上，你是我的住在美国的兄弟，你过着这种高度复杂的生活，你住在纽约市，每个人都对此印象深刻。
But you wouldn't be of us. I think the perception would be very different if you had done the same thing over the last 10 years in London, England. I think you would be perceived as being more Canadian still than having gone to the United States for 10 years. I suspect it might even be true if you had gone to another European country, that you would still be perceived as being more Canadian than you would be perceived now.
但你不会是我们的一员。我认为如果你在过去10年里在英国伦敦做了同样的事情，那种看法会非常不同。我认为你会比去美国10年被认为仍然更像加拿大人。我怀疑如果你去了另一个欧洲国家，你仍然会被认为比你现在被认为更像加拿大人的情况可能是真的。
But there's a way, because of the place that the United States has in the Canadian imagination, that going to America has a very special flavor to it.
但因为美国在加拿大想象中的地位，去美国有一种非常特殊的味道。
Yeah.
是的。
It means something.
它意味着什么。
Yeah.
是的。
And what is that? What does it mean?
那是什么？它意味着什么？
Well, not to put too fine a point on it, but I think in some ways, it's going over to the other side.
好吧，并不是要强调重点，但我认为在某些方面，它是去到另一边。
What about when other people move to the United States and musicians you like or actors you like or writers you like?
当你喜欢的人去美国，或者你喜欢的音乐家或你喜欢的演员或你喜欢的作家时呢？
Wayne Gretzky, let's just say.
韦恩·格雷茨基，我们就这么说吧。
Uh huh. The tragic trade.
嗯哼。悲剧的交易。
The tragic Wayne Gretzky story.
悲剧的韦恩·格雷茨基故事。
Not to mention the whole Winnipeg Jets team. Where are they now?
更不用说整个温尼伯喷气机队。他们现在在哪里？
Phoenix, of all places.
菲尼克斯，不管什么地方。
Phoenix, Arizona. What was that like? Were you there when the Jets moved to Phoenix?
亚利桑那州菲尼克斯。那是怎么样的？喷气机队搬到菲尼克斯时你在那里吗？
Yes, I was. It was just not pretty. It's just not pretty. I mean, it's a really deep sense of loss, I think, and betrayal for Canadians.
是的，我在那里。它只是不漂亮。它就是不漂亮。我的意思是，我认为这对加拿大人来说是一种非常深刻的失落和背叛感。
And who did they feel betrayed by?
他们觉得被谁背叛了？
Oh, whoever goes. And it's obviously not so rational all the time, right? So there's two things. There's a sense of betrayal, but there's also just a sense of sadness and a realization that that's the reality of the world and the economy that we live in. And also, maybe weariness, almost, when another one goes.
噢，不管谁走。这显然不是一直那么理性的，对吧？所以有两件事。有一种背叛感，但也有那种悲伤感，并意识到那是我们生活的世界和经济的现实。而且可能甚至感到疲惫，当另一个人走时。
Did you ever have any opinions about the fact that I was living in the United States? Do you ever feel like I had given up my birthright or denied my country?
你有没有觉得我住在美国的事实是一个意见？你有没有觉得我放弃了我的与生俱来的权利或否定了我的国家？
You are a bum.
你是一个流浪汉。
Not even necessarily in those terms. But did you ever feel sorry that I wasn't living in Canada?
甚至不一定是在那些条款中。但你有没有觉得我很遗憾我没住在加拿大？
I think only on a personal level. I don't think in any of those sort of philosophical ways. I think I would feel different, though, if you told me that you were deciding to become an American citizen. But I think until now, I've always felt like you're just living there and working there and eventually, you'll come back.
我认为只在个人层面上。我不认为以任何那种哲学方式。但如果如果如果你告诉我你决定成为美国公民，我会觉得不同。但我认为直到现在，我一直觉得你只是住在那里，在那工作，最终，你会回来。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Or it's not even that clear, but it's still that you belong here somehow. And even though you don't come back very much, somehow you're still Canadian.
是的。或者它甚至没有那么清楚，但你仍然以某种方式属于这里。尽管你不经常回来，但你仍然是加拿大人。
A lot of the Americans that I've spoken to have talked about how there's just no difference at all between Americans and Canadians, that Canadians are exactly the same as Americans. And, in fact, there are some people who say that in a really positive way.
我交谈过的很多美国人都谈到美国人和加拿大人之间根本没有区别，加拿大人和美国人完全一样。事实上，有些人以一种非常积极的方式说这一点。
[LAUGHS] Oh, don't worry. You're just like us.
[笑] 噢，别担心。你就像我们一样。
Exactly. There's no difference between you. You don't have to feel different. Just like whites would say to black-- [INTERPOSING]
正是。你们之间没有区别。你不需要感到不同。就像白人对黑人说——[插话]
Sure. Oh, you're really just like us.
当然。噢，你真的就像我们一样。
Exactly. So then, what's the answer? What do I say to people when they say, well, OK, what is Canadian?
正是。那么，答案是什么？当我的人说，嗯，OK，什么是加拿大人时，我该对他们说什么？
What does it mean to be Canadian?
身为加拿大人意味着什么？
Yeah, what's the Canadian-ness?
是的，什么是加拿大特色？
Yeah, I think that's really a struggle for Canadians. And in some way, I think it's that struggle that, ironically, defines what the answer is. I think in some ways, the answer is that a Canadian is someone who struggles to figure out what is to be Canadian and not American. And all of those things, it's really hard to make a pavilion about. There's that eternal problem of how do you make a Canadian knight? How do you make a Canadian pavilion? And you kind of have maple syrup, and that's the end of it. And we don't have a nice national dress and national food. And we have, well, the beaver, and not too much else.
是的，我认为这对加拿大人来说真的是一场斗争。在某种程度上，我认为正是那场斗争，具有讽刺意味地，定义了答案是什么。在某种程度上，答案是加拿大人是一个努力弄清楚什么是加拿大人而不是美国人的人。所有那些事情，真的很难制造一个展馆。有关于你怎么制造加拿大骑士的永恒问题。你怎么制造加拿大展馆？你有点枫糖浆，那就是它的终结。而且我们没有漂亮的民族服装和民族食物。而且我们有，嗯，海狸，和没有太多的别的东西。
Well, our program was produced by Nancy Updike, Paul Tough, and me, with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and Sylvia Lemus. And And did I mention Paul Tough?
好吧，我们的节目由南希·厄普代克、保罗·塔夫和我制作，与艾历克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。来自劳拉·多格特和西尔维娅·莱穆斯的制作帮助。还有我有提到保罗·塔夫吗？
Yes, Canadian.
是的，加拿大人。
Indeed, he is. Today's program was first broadcast back in 1997, hence the oddly anachronistic references to Beverly Hills 90210 .
确实，他是。今天的节目最初是在1997年广播的，因此有奇怪的对《飞越比弗利》的时代错误参考。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago-- 312-832-3380-- or visit our website where you can also listen to our programs for free-- absolutely free-- www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ——312-832-3380——或访问我们的网站，你也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目——绝对免费——www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播公司分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。
Yes, Canadian.
是的，加拿大人。
Oh, say it's not so. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
噢，说它不是这样。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播公司。